yeah but you don't seem and I'm gonna
say something to you and you might not
like it
oh great but I it's coming from love I
just realized that you don't you're the
you don't seem like a typical comedian
at all
hmm like now that I think about it I you
are always so kind of honest you know
like you like you'll just walk up to me
hey you're just there's nothing weird
about you there's no ulterior motive
there's no like you don't try to shame
like the other night Betty and yes
deeper I was talking I was it with you
no it's the Jeff just for laughs yeah
the the guys that booked it and they
came up to me and they went hey
congratulations we're so stoked that
this could work out because I'm going to
Montreal for the very first time this
year you've never done right I find that
hard to believe Bern walks up and goes
yeah but you're not gonna care because
he hasn't written a joke since 2002
right so he you know why would I just
say all comics slam you in that way to
like make just bit a little you a little
bit and you kind of go you know all of
them do that even like you know Billy
Perez said I love Steve I love mine and
I've I always thought you know I put him
up there's like one of the classiest
people in comedy right but he did do
that and then today I'm gonna show you
something right so today he texted me
right this is what he texted me right he
goes he goes so the last night he it was
happening last night so he last night
gfl he kind of you know I mean and then
today he goes yo I have a favor to ask
you
I have a documentary film about the
amazing Jonathan being released at ATC
on money whatever was wondering if I
could drop by your podcast to promote it
on the first or second week of June and
it took me eight hours to finally go yes
yeah because in those eight hours
without me it's him just sitting or
because I know he is the type of goes I
called
yesterday didn't call me back he's one
of those guys so I waited eight hours
Winkley it feels good and then finally
not much just yes no period nothing
right but so it's a very good way but
the thing is is that I I have like
little things you know mean like passive
aggressor passive aggressive and they
they poke and prod and they have their
issues but you are nothing like any of
them uh well I mean maybe I just keep my
issues well-hidden no I don't think that
I think that I think that you're just
you know a special breed like even you
know when he was coming on this podcast
three months I've been saying I have to
have him on the podcast we gotta figure
to fit him in right and people are going
yeah we'll get him in a venture I got no
because he because he's different
mm-hmm you know he you know I can't
explain it he's just you know a
different kind of a property kind of a
guy because people at the store you know
check out that profit I'm not saying I'm
not saying that you know you know to
blow smoke in your ass always up your
ass for in your ass yeah I don't know
what to taro how's the term gone up up
your eyes
[Music]